más civiles y policías heridos ha dejado
la segunda jornada de manifestaciones en
bogotá convocadas por el caso de abuso
policial que terminó con la vida del
abogado javier ordóñez en la madrugada
del miércoles y que provocaron las
muertes de al menos 10 personas en medio
de las protestas anoche los
manifestantes arrojaron piedras y
botellas a los agentes de varios centros
de atención inmediata conocidos como cai
en este atacaron las ventanas con una
señal de tráfico arrancada del piso e
incendiaron la fachada del lugar
la policía respondió con gases
lacrimógenos y granadas explosivas
haciendo que los manifestantes salieran
corriendo decenas de personas sufrieron
heridas por armas de fuego reiteramos
que tenemos evidencia sólida que
podremos en disposición de las
autoridades de la procuraduría general
de la nación de que no solo hubo abuso
policial el día de ayer sino uso
desmedido de la fuerza en particular de
armas de fuego razón por la cual hay 68
heridos con armas de fuego eso es bien
en combate
la alcaldesa prometió impulsar una
reforma a la policía y a su oficina
disciplinaria mientras tanto los dos
policías que sometieron por casi seis
minutos a javier ordóñez son ahora
investigados por parte de la fiscalía
por la gravedad de la afectación
evidenciada y por la competencia el día
de hoy he designado un fiscal
especializado de la dirección de
derechos humanos para que con rapidez y
debida diligencia lleve a los
responsables ante la justicia a través
de las redes sociales varios ciudadanos
han denunciado la situación e incluso
han dicho que uniformados hicieron
disparos al aire
en otras ciudades como medellín
barranquilla y cúcuta también hubo
manifestaciones en cali al suroeste de
colombia hubo enfrentamientos con la
policía y el transporte público fue
afectado